hey it's Elly here from Bowser from the
outdoor boy suit to tell and today we're
going to be building a frog box this is
my pet frog I know
I think we need two more
let's go get some more
hello call it are you going to be
joining it hi and you aren't going now
looks like enough cardboard now let's
keep the carving let's get the car here
we need to go someplace we need the duct
tape that one worked our work that's
what we I was looking for good table
[Music]
thanks for watching thank you guys for
watching thank you for watching I hope
you I hope you liked it click Subscribe
see you next Saturday if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching